hey everyone welcome back to GameSpot's
III stage we are kicking off a week of
demos up here on our upstairs stage I'm
your host Mike McCarty here with Rob
Henry hi and we are pleased to be joined
by a couple people working on Star Wars
Battlefront 2 Paul Kesling and Craig
McLeod hey and you're both producers on
this project right yep and we finally
got to glimpse the multiplayer because
you know like I think leading up to now
right like Rob and I both played the
first game and as a lot of people did
but the thing that we were interested in
was the single-player how they're going
to take a story especially from the
Imperial side of things right we have
new character and bridging the gap
between Return of the Jedi and force
awakens but now we've seen multiplayer
and a host of things have changed there
as well Paul like what were we looking
at yesterday when we saw this the
gameplay like it's kind of a broad
question because there's a lot there was
there was a ton going on
there's a ton going on I mean we've got
a new battle point system we've got a
way for people to become those iconic
heroes we've got new classes we've got
we you know we said a lot of stuff we've
all got more depth everywhere we've got
improved gate gun play so a lot of
through gun experience you're gonna
you're going to see and get your hands
on it's gonna everyone's gonna feel a
bit different you're definitely gonna
want to pick out some of your favorites
I mean we've got a whole host of stuff I
mean I Craig Craig can talk about some
of the great Star Wars epicness that
we've brought to the title as well yeah
no absolutely I mean for us it was
really about I mean actually if we think
back to the first game when we think
what was that big magical moment
everyone had it was that Walker so on
Hoth because you know you finally got
transported to this place that you've
always wanted to go to and this is what
we want to bring to every single planet
that we have and so right here you see
that you know we're we're approaching
we're in Theed this is part of our run
up where you get to see all these MTTs
deploying all these droids really
showing the scale of the invasion that
we have within this movie making sure
that we invoke the fantasy in the
essence of the location which we're in
yeah even excuse me even seeing like the
NPCs and beginning scatter about like as
if this is a real life event happening
was super enjoyable that's a city under
siege yeah absolutely because I mean a
lot of people services like you know
where where's all the destruction
where's the big discussion from
battlefield well you know that's not
Star Wars that's that's not part of that
universe we work a lot with Lucasfilm to
make sure
we stay true to that universe so blaster
bolts will you know they'll make scorch
marks as opposed to bringing down
buildings but what we have is we have
this incredible living world where you
cease yeah like you say civilians
playing you know we have a whole bunch
of wildlife it just really feels really
alive and dynamic yeah I'm curious
obviously the this battle that we've
seen is comes from like you know farther
back like toward the you know the
prequel era right like what was the
choice that went into that do you say
did you know for right from the bat that
you wanted to go into the prequel era as
well as doing like new things and more
modern settings I think yeah absolutely
we we knew that we we started in the
original trilogy I think that's a great
place to build a foundation but we knew
that we want to branch out you know we
knew that the prequels for a huge
portion of our audience was actually
their first touch point into Star Wars
you know they started with it with the
Phantom Menace and therefore Naboo in
Theed so we definitely want to bring
these places to life such as feeds such
as Kamino
and others that you may have seen in our
trailer it's a really exciting time for
us it is and I think you know Craig
touched on a little bit is that's
something that fans wanted you know
they've been asking for more Star Wars
and you know like you said with the
Clone Wars being some of the the first
touch points for people you know but and
what else is the new hotness right now
in Star Wars it's it's the last Jedi so
you know how are we gonna how we gonna
bring that stuff to the people that's
you know something we can constantly
think about is how do we tie into them
what's happening in Star Wars yeah
I'm here's when you're looking at the
multiplayer from the first game and you
know like you're thinking what do we
want to do is see what do we want to
change what were the main did you have
any main tenets that you wanted to kind
of really add to this second game to
differentiate it I think one of the
first things was just more team play you
know we had a partner system before but
it didn't really allow the team play
that a lot of people had known from a
dice game so for us it was about
creating not only ability to form
parties so that you can stay together
but also this organic team play which we
have with our spawn right system and
also our class system so now you know
you can you can go into a match with
some buddies you'll naturally form into
this little source staging area where
you can see oh these are the people I'm
paired up with stay together I get
bonuses for staying together it doesn't
matter what I'm doing whether I'm
getting kills playing the objective
whether you know I'm just I'm buffing my
teammates there's so there's so much
reason to stay together as a team and
work as a unit yeah I think you know
Craig
touched on it with talk about all the
teamwork and when we have the new
classes that's we've really opened it up
for players to say how do I fill a role
on the battlefield do I want to be a
specialist and be that long-range fire
support downrange or do I want to be a
heavy but like you're seeing here you
know push in the front lines or maybe
pushing in to a point with that shield
meanwhile maybe your friends got your
back he's an officer he's keeping you
healthy and keeping you alive helping
you push into that point so it's
allowing for that those great dynamic
team play options yeah that's the the
main takeaway I've had and Rob you could
probably talk about this too because you
have played the game at this camp the
multiplayer but it does seem like
whereas the first game when I was
playing it gave me that spectacle of
Star Wars they're gonna be like it gave
me like the surface appeal of a Star
Wars game I felt like I was in a
starburst and I felt like I was on Hoth
the 80 80s or had that's whether you
want to say we're coming at me I'm an
eighty eighty per second sorry ya know
say okay cool uh but anyway yeah it
seems like you're you're deepening a lot
of the systems in the sense that you're
making it much more of a shooter rather
than just the Star Wars game with like
light shooter aspects um
Robbie I want to ask you kind of is that
the impression you got after playing it
yeah absolutely even seeing you know it
this is a perfect timing as far as
footage goes when you are picking your
class and then you get to see what
everyone else is and then there's I
think it's the bottom right it says you
know stay close with your four or three
other teammates to get those battle
points exponentially raised and
instinctively you're just like well if
everyone's going to be a sport well
maybe I should be an officer right I'm
gonna try to you know lengthen my time
on the battlefield before I die and I've
definitely found that drive which is
really nice opposed to like the previous
game where you know you do have that
cool partner system but I always tend to
just be a lone wolf like and just kind
of go out and get myself inevitably
killed but yeah of the two matches I
played which you know again yeah the
spectacle was really spectacular but
yeah I would say moving on the thing
that I really didn't think you guys
would do uh and got me extremely excited
was the four ship combat the rolling
option yeah manual roll Emmanuel roll
was huge for any person who knows how
like you know it's it's how you fly any
kind of plane and so many times in
battlefront the previous game I would
get frustrated you know doing the flip
and then doing a nosedive
and it's tough to recover from that
without then finding yourself maybe
upside down or you know you the game
would have to kind of auto roll for you
and in turn make you feel like you had
less control and control felt really on
us that's great and I think that's
that's what we tried to do with adding
depth to the game is we know people you
know we got feedback from fans and they
wanted a bit more that that option to
control playing specifically so the guys
over criterion have done a great job
helping revamp what that feels like and
making sure that you have a little bit
more tactical options when you're in
that in a air fighter and that's very
tough to do too because I mean you know
if only everyone could like understand
those controls but it is tough right
like you you're kind of not alienating
your audience but it's you're you're
never going to lose people potentially
who are going to maybe find that hard to
do and I'm sure you guys have options to
simplify the controls yeah I think I
think that I mean that's one of the
differences that we've done with this
game is that we're keeping that
accessibility right so people will still
be able to get in they'll have familiar
controls but for those who want to
really master it or who want to take it
to the next level and really be rewarded
for that that skill that they've learned
then we have those options there for you
all right
or on the other hand you know if you if
you're not good in a fighter there's
plenty of other vehicles or iconic
characters that you're able to jump into
so there's plenty of options for
everybody I love that a TRT the 18 is my
favorite I think it's chance to use that
that looks like love on that Walker yeah
absolutely the clone Walker it's super
agile super nimble you know as it starts
sprinting through the streets it's
looking like a velociraptor you know
banners absolutely it's something it's
an incredible vehicle I love the
mobility of it yeah while we're watching
Darth Maul do his so battle points are
very new as well it's not these tokens
you pick up and Wright was in the first
game Paul could you tell me about the
way that you actually can unlike heroes
or these ships that Rob is talking about
yeah absolutely so like you mentioned we
got rid of the token system that we had
in the first game that was something
that that fans had you know positive
negative reactions to but is something
that we thought we could do better with
and this time around as you're playing
the game as you're earning battle points
through any action whether it be you
know you're getting kills or you're
assisting your you're buffing your team
as an officer you're playing the
objective like we always want people to
do you're earning points that kind of
fuel you to be able to become something
bigger and better now you can either you
know maybe you want to save up your
points and just go straight for
or you know do you say hey in the in
this case of being a separatist I want
to be a bee tube droid try to get a
whole bunch of kills to keep my a
snowballing effect of earning more and
more battle points so they become a hero
faster you know how do you want to take
your kind of journey there to getting a
new character yeah to look at another
dice title and I was when I played
battlefield one last year right
obviously very different games but when
I was playing battlefield one the depth
of it obviously it's a more traditional
battlefield game I was saying I wish
that the first battlefront had done more
of this in terms of depth and it seems
like if you did you guys you look at
battlefield one and all in terms of how
they do multiplayer things and what you
can implement in battlefront too I think
it's a I mean absolutely right so I mean
battlefield one is you know it's one of
our games from our studio and we talked
to that team a lot and we can take
monies for them but it's about it's not
just cocking right we can't we don't
just want to either risk in a
battlefield or just steal a system we
need to make sure that it fits the
universe and fits our player base and
this is where it's been you know a lot
of listening to our community working
with the game changers the game cheers
is being fantastic for us we've had them
over at our studios so many times and
you know their feedback has been
invaluable they've really helped to sort
of shape the game that we have today and
curious why was a feed the first one you
decided to show like for multiplayer
purposes I mean obviously it looks
really fun and it looks great but I'm
curious there any other reasons that
this the one you're gonna like come out
at e3 with yeah so I mean thieved was it
was actually an easy option for us we've
heard so many people shouting like we
want to see prequels so many people
shouting like we want to see Darth Maul
we want to see that acrobatic amazing
hero it's a great way to show off that
you know from our first game we had a
lot of environmental maps now we're
looking now we're having a mixture right
we want to bring more urban maps in
there for a lot of first-person shooter
players it's actually really important
to sort of know what wolves are behind
me you know where are my angles and
things like that so it's about adding
that diversity and another great thing
that it does is it shows the full dice
sandbox so when we think about that
ground layer of infantry vehicles and
then of course the aerial layer which
I'm sure as you've seen as you were
playing yeah the starfighters we've
managed to integrate the area layer much
more with the ground layer so that it
feels much
cohesive as a full experience yeah you
know like we keep seeing these uh class
selection screen come up and I am
curious was there an effort to lend like
more longevity to the game with this
progression yeah I mean we're not going
to go too in depth on progression right
now but you can see in some of these
screens that we've got the the star
cards there in the upper right was what
does that character have equipped so you
know there's some things that are
specific to that character class but
there's also some things that we allow
you to customize a little bit more a
little bit more flexibility in terms of
how do you want to play your class so
say right now we're looking at the heavy
who's got the combat shield so he can
block him incoming damage he also has
his signature ability which is he got
into a sentry mode where he can lay down
a ton of cover fire but that third slot
on the right you know that's a little
bit you can you can mix that one up do
you want grenades do you want a sticky
bomb we'll give you a bunch of different
options to play around with and you know
you'll be able to unlock all these
things via via loot crate's during our
progression so you'd be able to
constantly earn better and better
rewards different abilities you're able
to swap those in and out so it's we're
trying to give a lot more flexibility to
players and also predictability right as
far as this is a support class you know
generally what he's right gonna give you
when you're facing off with exactly
something really minor
well maybe not really minor but
something I just saw is the active
reload kind of thing like a play right
yep so so that one is you know we've
carried over from the last game where we
had an overheat system and you were
tabled in the first game to just do a
fast cooldown and get through that now
we've added a little bit more depth
there there's actually a few more things
in play now you can manually manually
cool-cool your your gun so if you've
build up heat maybe halfway and you're
like you know what I don't want to push
it all the way to the edge and then have
it go through its cooldown animation you
know it's just like reloading in
battlefield just I push it mm-hmm it'll
instantly cool down a little bit quicker
so it little bit bit more depth there
but the other thing that used that you
saw was kind of a super cool down so if
you hit that one you have you're not
going to generate heat for like the next
few seconds on your gun and you just can
keep firing wait for even longer so it's
you know it's that skill game where do
you want to go do you know maybe you're
running in between engagements I can
manually cool down that's fine you're
free in the heat of battle you're like
okay I really need a lot of firepower I
hope I get that super cool down of
course there's always that risk reward
if you miss it it's gonna be hurtin yeah
and then I just also want to talk about
the the game-mode that we're watching
here because I don't know if we've
touched on that yet um useless cuz it
seems like it's like you know a very
objective based and then obviously
you're moving through feed as an
attacker and then the defenders are kind
of trying to take out these troop
transports and defend these key points
can we talk about that yeah absolutely
so I mean this is our new signature game
mode this is galactic soul and it
actually starts in it has phases we
decided to bring in sort of more face
based gameplay so we we started off with
this big open vehicle sandbox is where
you're escorting the MTT through the
street of speed to get to the palace in
an effort to actually breach that palace
and get inside from the first game
usually that would be the only
experience from Walker assault as you
would escort that Walker and then to be
over and what we want to do is we want
to extend that experience and add more
depth more and more of a dynamic
storytelling within the game so once you
get to that palace what happens is then
we go into that palace and we have now
we have more of a tight infantry
gameplay this is where our our elite
units such as the clone drum trooper in
the b-2 battle droid really can start to
come to the forefront they have more
health and they have a bit more
firepower and then of course our heroes
will start to dominate once you get into
that first stage of the palace you look
to overwrite that security system and if
you're successful in doing that you
really create this final last stand in
the throne room for like that epic
showdown at the end yeah Rob you played
han Solo at some point right was that
you yeah was he like huh oh really fun I
mean I actually am one compared to the
last game who wasn't really I got I'm
like all-star fighter to be honest like
the heroes for me didn't do much but
there was something about Han Solo this
time around that just made it really
worthwhile I mean I liked the fact that
there wasn't like an intro animation for
him it was kind of just like felt more
alive in the world I guess I want to say
but his moves were for me at least more
understandable I like the prompts in the
bottom right that said like this was you
know your sharpshooter it was clearly a
just hell fire move of his that yeah I
got to pull off at some point I was just
like it was coming into a hallway and
there's like a bunch of like battle
droids focused on like a different door
it's just like I finally had that moment
like okay I know to do here
like seriously learning skills yeah
heroes are awesome I and I found them
more like I someone wants a weaker like
they're not so overpowered maybe you
could say from the last game where you
see Luke Skywalker hopping towards you
from across a map like you know you're
done for um but here it felt like yeah
you could you could really do some
damage on Darth Maul or whoever it is
and that was a conscious decision you
know we were allowing for more heroes to
be on the battlefield at any time we
have the ability for you to have a bunch
of these iconic units like the b2 the
clone jump trooper so we're gonna have a
lot of combined arms going on with a
bunch of different things and since
that's that's the case you can't say
that if heroes are super overpowered and
there's more of them on the on the field
completely imbalances things on fun way
so it's it's still a bit of a balance
there but the goal for it is that if
you're an organized group working
together you can take down a hero fairly
quickly if you're if you're good at it
but you know if the hero character is
skilled and again this is somebody that
skill gap he can overcome this and just
use his abilities to their fullest
we saw some that Darth Maul gameplay
earlier and that guy was just shredding
it because he was was playing smart he's
playing smart but if I if you team up
and you work well you know given all the
classes that you have access to and the
different abilities you can really take
it to the heroes and I also find it
really great that you know again
compared to last game were you know it
was very random and and more or less
unlikely that you could get a hero
because of that that power option but
hero is like for me I was surprised how
I could get a han Solo
like pretty consistently if I decided to
save my battle points and take that risk
which makes that time with said hero
like high tech like high tense you know
uh intensity but as far as the ability
to like shift to a clone trooper or the
super Bala droid like you can get more
action with that based on the battle
point so yeah absolutely I mean we we
got that feedback a lot where people are
saying you know we love the heroes but I
never got to play one or I didn't get to
play one for like five six seven eight
nine rounds right and so what we really
want to do is make sure that we had more
heroes and more often and we can do that
by making sure they have strengths and
weaknesses so they're not so overpowered
but now we have more heroes in the frase
you might see instead of just one versus
one here um now you might see two versus
two or who knows even more and I think
that that's that's a great thing about
having multiple
was on the battlefield is now you know
before maybe we only balanced around
individually how two heroes match up on
a one-on-one basis but now it's like you
know if in this instance we have rey
here
Rey has the ability to to mind trick
people which inverts your control so
that you know that temporary like oh
crap what am i doing
that allows Han Solo to to really come
in and start cleaning up so it's not
necessarily about her being a super
killer right but she's she's a great
disabler she's somebody that can mess
with the enemy team and it's that that
inter team played between heroes
themselves on a faction so this is a lot
more options there let more depth to the
heroes that way yeah it's it's kind of a
tangent but it's weird that you know
like the last time we've seen like super
battle droids or battle droids or Naboo
in a battlefront was not a game that
like dice was working on it was the
older games which of course like this
huge following sprang up around them and
then you know like when you come into
like trying to take on that franchise I
imagine it must have been daunting with
the first game but even more so like is
there kind of this overarching pressure
at all to live up to Lexi those left
behind obviously those aren't games you
made but there has to be some sort of
like shadow looming over things like
it's had a great showing so far to show
and everything in between the single
player and everything new you're doing
multiplayer seems like you're you're on
a great track but I have to ask that
like is there any like feeling of we
have to kind of live up to the legacy I
mean I mean anytime you actually work
with Star Wars whether you're comparing
two older games or whether you're trying
to invoke the essence the movies of
course there's you know there's pressure
and because they're so special to people
right and even when you think back to
the old Battlefront so you know sort of
ten years or just over ten years ago you
know people have such fond memories and
they you know they want a break they
want that essence that they had from
that game that's brought into you know a
new generation working with these new
consoles and I we've been we've been
very respectful to working with
Lucasfilm as well has been an absolute
privilege to to make sure that we stay
true to the universe we stay true to the
games and also to the battlefront
franchise and I think that's something
that we as a studio have been a very
mindful very respectful of and I hope
you know I hope our fans are
appreciating it yeah I mean we try to
bring so much so much authenticity to
the game because we know that maybe the
Star Wars that that you remember from
episode one isn't the same one that
I remember but is it does it feel
authentic does it feel believable when
you jump in and you play you're like you
know what this feels right to me I I
would expect this to happen if I were in
a play in that universe yeah imagine
must be a two-sided coin right on one
hand it must be pretty terrifying to be
taking on Star Wars right like there's
so many people it's it's a it's a
cultural phenomenon like maybe the
biggest thing America that's older and
you have to make a game set in that
universe yeah that's pretty daunting but
on the other side you're working with
Star Wars right it's it's a like you
said the beginning like now you can go
into the prequel era I imagine you're
going to go into like first-order
resistance kind of territory yeah
absolutely I mean we're hitting all
three eras right any what we want to do
the prequels one do the classic we want
do the new we want to bring in you know
vehicles heroes troopers from all these
errors and really just create what we
feel is the you know the essential Star
Wars shooter that that's really how we
think of it as as a team and it's a
studio where you know whether you're a
shooter fan or whether you're a star
wars fan
this is the game for you yeah Robbi
think it's all I had to ask you anything
yeah I'm very excited to play more of
this cool yeah right Paul and Craig
thanks so much for coming on thank you
so much yeah have a great rest of the
show I go to thank you and for every
watching you can keep getting more news
off our e3 stage up here we'll also be
having co-op stages downstairs will be
used live streaming all week having
people on to talk about great games with
battlefront too and we'll see you then